this is about the constitution of United
States and it's important to the
president to know important to know the
American voter voters in America should
decide who our president is not vadym or
pluton Putin in Russia so today I'm very
proud to present the managers who will
bring the case which we have great
confidence in in terms of impeaching the
president and its removal
but this further evidence insist of that
and we wouldn't be in this situation had
we not waited insists that there be that
there be witnesses and that we see
documentation and now you see some of
that change happening on the Senate side
I hope it does for the good of our
country and to honor our Constitution so
today on the floor will pass a
resolution naming the managers as I
mentioned appropriating the funds for
the trial and transmitting the articles
of impeachment of the President of the
United States for trying to influence a
foreign government for his own personal
and political benefit chair Adam Schiff
of California lead managers kept
Chairman Schiff is as you know chair of
the permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence is serving his tenth term
in Congress excuse me before Congress
mr. Schiff was a California state
senator and served as a federal
prosecutor in the US Attorney's Office
in Los Angeles for six years most
notably prosecuting the first federal
FBI agent remember to be indicted for
espionage chairman Jerry Nadler chair of
the House Judiciary Committee is serving
his fifteenth German Congress mr. Nadler
served as the top Democrat on the
Judiciary Subcommittee on Constitution
civil rights and civil liberties for 13
years
before Congress mr. Nadler served the
New York State Assembly for 16 years
well Cera's ol often chairs Olaf and
chair of the House Committee on house
administration which has jurisdiction
over federal elections as a senior
member of the House Judiciary Committee
mr. Lufkin is serving her 13th term in
Congress this is chairwoman Lauren's
third impeachment as a judiciary
committee staffer and the Nixon
impeachment as a member of the Judiciary
Committee under the Clinton impeachment
and now as a manager in this impeachment
of President Trump chair hop came
Jeffries of New York chairman Hakeem
Jeffries is the chair of the House
Democratic caucus and is currently
serving his fourth fourth term in
Congress he's a member of the House
Judiciary Committee before being in
Congress he served in the assembly of
New York for six years and accomplished
litigator and private practice before
running for elective office mr. Jeffrey
Jeffries church for clerked for the
Honorable Howard Baer Jr of New York
District Court for the Southern District
of New York congresswoman Dowell Danny
Demmings of Florida congresswoman Dowell
Demings is a member of both the house
permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence and the House Judiciary
Committee miss Debbie's serving her
second term in Congress before Congress
miss Deming serves the Orlando Police
Department for 27 years part of that
time as the first woman police chief in
Orlando congressman chisme Congressman
Jason crow of Colorado was a member of
the House Armed Services Committee mr.
crow served his country our country
bravely as an Army Ranger in Iraq and
Afghanistan before coming running for
Congress mr. crow was a respected
litigator in private practice in
Colorado
congresswoman Sylvia Garcia of Texas
congressman Sylvia Garcia is a member of
the House Judiciary Committee before
Congress miss miss Garcia was served in
Texas State Senate previously
she was the director and presiding judge
of the Houston municipal system and was
elected city controller miss Garcia was
later elected the first Hispanic and
first woman to be elected in her own
right to the Harris County Commissioners
Court as you can see from these
descriptions of the emphasis is on
litigators the emphasis is on comfort
level in the courtroom the emphasis is
making the strongest possible case to
protect and defend our Constitution to
seek the truth for the American people
I'm very proud and honored that these
seven members distinguished members have
accepted this serious responsibility
again to protect and defend for the
people defending our democracy